the decision could have an impact on how
companies treat many of their employees
both gay and heterosexual bloomers Jeff
Green has been looking into that side of
the story and Jeff you could argue that
a corporate culture has been shifting in
this direction already making it
possible for couples that are in
same-sex marriages or relationships to
have health care benefits and other
other insurance coverage through their
through their spouse or their partner
right about 94 95 maybe even higher than
that percent of companies offer the
benefit to same-sex couples who are
domestic partners who up to this point
obviously couldn't be married couples
the the interesting thing is many of
those companies may drop that benefit
for domestic partner Bennett couples and
now that it's now they can be married in
other words that the companies would
insist that they be married in order to
qualify for these benefits yeah the way
the way the numbers breakdown is take 90
some percent are for same-sex couples
and only sixty-two percent include
opposite sex couples and in the survey
that was done by a by the group that
represents all the like a risk of people
it looked at it was about twenty percent
said they would probably drop domestic
partner benefits for same-sex couples
once this ruling came by this was just
in the last week so this is a cost issue
for them in terms of finding any way
they can to reduce their expenses for
people who are not direct employees and
it's not just cost I mean the idea is
that it's complexity to give same-sex
benefits there's a lot of stuff they do
the that they have to do
administratively to kind of true this
all up to make it the same the real
problem for the gay couples may come in
by saying that they're married they open
themselves up to discrimination because
while it's legal to be married now in
all 50 states it's not legal to be gay
in all 50 states for you can
discriminate against people because of
their gay me guess it's legal to be gay
but they can discriminate against you
legally still in more than 20 states so
by having a certificate that says I'm
married and I'm gay somebody can say
well fine then you can't rent an
apartment
from me things like that yeah which
kinds of companies or what kinds of
companies in which industries have been
reluctant to offer benefits to same-sex
couples unfortunately they don't break
it out in a way that you can tell which
industries it is it does tend to be
coastal is more support in the coastal
areas than in the middle of the country
kind of how you might expect it this
also becomes an issue and the bigger
companies are more supportive than the
small companies because the bigger
companies recognize these people have to
go across borders they have their
tractor negotiating trying to get talent
from all over the world and that is
another issue is you want to send your
company or your employees overseas and
now they have a record of being in a gay
marriage it's still illegal to be gay in
many countries where we do a lot of
business up till now there's kind of
been a wink nod kind of thing where you
would list your family if you were gay
as household staff if you also have a
record of being married to one of them
that becomes a lot more difficult Jeff
does this also create legal
responsibilities that may not have
existed before for people that would
become married yeah definitely I mean
there's a whole lot of things that this
plays into in terms of divorce a
domestic partner arrangement didn't
necessarily give you the same rights to
the estate if you get if you ended it
we're being married we'll obviously you
know create a lot of legal entanglements
that didn't exist there's there's tax
implications there's lots of
implications that come into this I mean
now you're married it's all the same
stuff that regular married couples in
the same sex situation Hector different
opposite sex have to deal with are now
going to be something you have to think
about the same reasons maybe some people
who don't get married who are
heterosexual now apply to gay couples
Jeff hold on for a second because we
want to show you a tweet that Hillary
Clinton just tweeted out in response to
the Supreme Court decision the
Democratic presidential nominee tweeting
out proud to celebrate a historic
victory for marriage equality and the
courage and she continues to say and
determination of LGBT Americans who made
it possible each so Hillary Clinton
coming out in support of the Supreme
Court decision where
so I want to bring into Bloomberg's phil
mattingly who's been tracking this
decision and Phil now that Hillary
Clinton has gone to the public airwaves
with her comments obviously we're going
to wait for Republican challengers to
offer their so what can we expect look I
am I think there again this is a
difficult issue for them in general
because you look at the nationwide
polling and again think about it look at
it from this perspective guys this is 11
years since the first state legalized
same-sex marriage over the course of 11
years the public opinion shift on this
has been stunning there's really no
other way to put it on from it from the
perspective of social change I don't
know that you've ever seen something
change this quickly in this
transformative of a way that said
Republicans on this issue particularly
as they look at a primary in the
competitive primary where conservatives
just don't agree with this in any way
shape or form are not going to get too
far out in front they're not going to
make some big grand statement accepting
the Supreme Court ruling what you're
largely going to hear from them is
opposition to how this came down
continued opposition to same-sex
marriage but possibly some massaging the
language of the Supreme Court has spoken
it's time to move on I think that is
probably as far out as you're going to
get to see somebody get I think we also
just got a tweet from President Obama
who said quote this is a bit today is a
big step forward in our march towards
equality an interesting point there Pam
President Obama when he ran for election
in 2008 was against same-sex marriage he
has as he quoted himself evolved on the
issue over the time period so has
Hillary Clinton so underscoring the way
this change has occurred in such a quick
fashion when our current president who
is now trumpeting this case and this
victory for equality first set foot in
office he did not believe that this was
the pathway to go at least publicly and
now he does and I think guys what I've
heard from the White House this morning
is there's a pretty good chance we'll
probably hear from him publicly about
this before he heads down to Charleston
to eulogize one of the victims of the
the shooting the ninth the ninth at were
killed in the shooting just last week
yeah a lot of people are going to say
that the president was the opportunistic
and how he
asia's view or at least declared
outright his support for gay marriage I
do want to bring in sudden context to
the Supreme Court decision as we
mentioned as pin mentioned it was a
five-to-four decision here with Justice
Anthony Kennedy writing the majority
statement that announced everything
let's give you the quote here that he
wrote Justice Anthony Kennedy in joining
the courts for Democratic appointees the
majority said no union is more profound
than marriage for it embodies the
highest ideals of love fidelity devotion
sacrifice and family Jeff Green over to
you we were talking earlier about how
many companies had moved ahead of this
because the tide of public opinion has
changed so much and they were making
allowances for same-sex couples when it
comes to benefits health care benefits
retirement benefits some saw all that
can you contrast that with how the
federal government and other state
employees are treated well the federal
government it you know that was where we
had the previous Supreme Court decision
I can't say state-by-state how this
plays out I mean that obviously had been
legal in and at least more than half the
states already so this is more kind of
bringing the rest of the country in line
the fact that the companies are behind
this is actually the key thing here the
companies have been a big part in
pushing everybody to get this towards us
equality discussion and that's sort of
the expectation now that this is going
to set up the companies to get behind a
push to now go to the states where you
can still legally discriminate against
people for the sexuality and get those
laws changed so that's sort of the next
frontier for companies in this is these
people have a great infrastructure the
the LGBT group now has a great
infrastructure in place and a lot of
companies on board and companies are
really being pressured to show their
support so the next sort of frontier and
all this will be to get the states that
don't currently allow people to be gay
without fear of discrimination to get in
line with the marriage decision Jeff
does this also affect tax filing
something as prosaic as sending your
money the government question well yeah
I mean clearly if you get married and
you know the limit for a single person
is 200 the limit for a married couple is
250 and they start to go up a tax
bracket if you take two people who make
two hundred grand
and put them together now you make 400
you just jumped a tax bracket you know
the kind of the marriage tax applies to
everyone who gets married it's all that
kind of stuff but I don't think many
people are going to look at this as a
you know like oh you know as a defeat
because they they have to file different
taxes but that's the kind of
considerations they can still file
single it's just those sort of things
that come into it are